how did coin base become what it is
today
so
let me ask on an engineering question
actually sort of
uh from the the ruby wallet days
what are some of the interesting
challenges there or are they not
engineering just the the things that had
to be solved uh what were they
engineering
regulation
um
financial hiring
lawyers
what was it
so post product market fit yeah a lot of
it's scaling and you gotta build up
build out an actual company so
i remember i was still writing a lot of
code there for a while and we were we
were hiring in we had like maybe 25
people or something i remember one of
our investors came by one day and he was
like brian how much your time are you
spending writing code i was like
maybe maybe 50 or something he was like
how much time are you spending hiring
people i was like probably 20
and he was like
i think you need to flip those numbers
like this company's not going to scale
you're the ceo you don't need to be
writing code every day
you're going to have to transition that
stuff like even if people can't all that
stuff's locked in your head so maybe
they're not gonna do it as well as you
for the first six months or something
but like if you don't start to
transition it you're never gonna build a
real company it's just gonna be
you're gonna be the bottleneck
so you know like a lot of founders
that took me a while to like really
internalize that lesson i'd always heard
people say that and you know
but i still was holding on too much to
decision making and i probably still am
by the way like even to this day at
coinbase where
we uh continually have to push down
decision making in the org like even
5000 people like who are the owners of
each of these things and so the
temptation is people to push it up and
you become a bottleneck and anyway
um
so yeah you want you basically need to
make sure you have enough money where
you don't die
if there's in some some kind of a
downturn or hit break even in
profitability we were in a position
where we were periodically profitable
during up periods but then crypto would
go down and we were unprofitable and so
we had to kind of manage our own
psychology and the balance sheet to make
sure we didn't like die in the downturn
which a lot of crypto companies did
um we had to basically professionalize a
whole bunch of services that had been
just very quickly thrown together by
like 20 year olds right
whether that was cyber security it's
like okay how do you get like a really
senior experienced cyber security person
but not someone who's so senior that
they can't get their hands dirty and
they can come into a company with 25 50
people
how do you get a finance person to come
and do that our finances were
a mess like we didn't even really know
how much money we had at certain times
and stuff i mean this was it's
embarrassing to say but it was true like
i remember there was a point where um
we we had raised i think like our series
c or something like that and
i think we had our bank accounts and i
just put like 25 million dollars like in
a different bank account that none of
this stuff was touched to the actual
operation the business because i was
like
you know our operations were so messy
and we needed to hire a new finance
person and i was like this
i had heard horror stories of actually
startups where they thought they had x
amount of money
and then it turned out they had way less
and then the whole thing was insolvent
in like three weeks so you wanted to
have some padding too yes like all right
i can't at least count on this to save
us if we go to like super negative right
i mean it was like a cheap hack but that
was like don't even come up with and you
know until we could hire like a real cfo
and finance team who like
okay now we got our arms around how much
cash we have it sounds silly but we had
such high
volume of money coming in and out anyway
what was the ordering of hiring by the
way
like uh
how many engineers was it early on you
said cfo was not did you even have a cfo
for a bit yeah like what was the
[Music]
the landscape of hiring as you building
up this company
was it engineering focused
well let's see i mean so the first
person we hired was just like
we need we need to solve customer
support so we brought someone to do that
because we were all staying up till
midnight every night trying to do
customer support and then
we got more engineers and then i think
maybe the sixth higher or something like
that was a recruiter because that that
turned out to be you know you need to
build hire the person who can hire more
people yeah that turned out to be a
great
forced multiplier and then
you go on down the list eventually you
want to hire some more senior people
um we needed legal and compliance we
needed that really badly because we you
know there's all kinds of questions
about what the legality of it was was it
hard to find legal people that work with
crypto like serious adults
because it's such a cutting-edge new
world yeah i mean there was nobody who
had like more than
nobody had three years of experience
with it because it had only been around
a few years so yeah we were finding
people from adjacent fields
there's a certain personality type of
people who are willing to join early
companies because they have no structure
you can't really commit to them about
you're gonna have this team or this
boss or whatever like everything's in
chaos and flux
so
it takes
yeah hiring is one of the hardest things
in the early stage for sure you got to
find people crazy enough to join you in
this journey
you